[Music]
each year in the United States players
of sports and recreational activities
receive between 2.5 and 4 million
concussions how dangerous are all those
concussions the answer is complicated
and lies in how the brain responds when
something strikes it the brain is made
of soft fatty tissue with a consistency
something like jello inside its
protective membranes and the skulls hard
casing this delicate organ is usually
well shielded but a sudden jolt can make
the brain shift and bump against the
skulls hard interior and unlike jello
the brains tissue isn't uniform it's
made of a vast network of ninety billion
neurons which relays signals through
their long axons to communicate
throughout the brain and control our
bodies this spindle II structure makes
them very fragile so that when impacted
neurons will stretch and even tear that
not only disrupts their ability to
communicate but as destroyed axons begin
to degenerate they also release toxins
causing the death of other neurons -
this combination of events causes a
concussion the damage can manifest in
many different ways including blackout
headache blurry vision balance problems
altered mood and behavior problems with
memory thinking and sleeping and the
onset of anxiety and depression every
brain is different
which explains why people's experiences
of concussions vary so widely
luckily the majority of concussions
fully heal and symptoms disappear within
a matter of days or weeks lots of rest
and a gradual return to activity allows
the brain to heal itself on the subject
of rest many people have heard that
you're not supposed to sleep shortly
after receiving a concussion because you
might slip into a coma
that's a myth so long as doctors aren't
concerned there may also be a more
severe brain injury like a brain bleed
there's no documented problem with going
to sleep after a concussion sometimes
victims of concussion can experience
something called post concussion
syndrome or the PCs people with pcs may
experience constant headaches learning
difficulties and behavioral symptoms
that even affect their personal
relationships for months or years after
the injury trying to play through a
concussion even for only a few minutes
or returning to sports too soon after a
concussion makes it more likely to
develop pcs in some cases a concussion
can be hard to diagnose because the
symptoms unfold slowly over time that's
often true of sub-concussive impacts
which result from lower impact jolts to
the head than those that cause
concussions this category of injury
doesn't cause a noticeable symptoms
right away but can lead to severe
degenerative brain diseases over time if
it happens repeatedly take soccer
players who are known for repeatedly
heading soccer balls using a technique
called diffusion tensor imaging we're
beginning to find out what effect that
has on the brain this method allows
scientists to find large axon bundles
and see how milder blows might alter
them structurally in 2013 researchers
using this technique discovered that
athletes who had headed the ball the
most about 1,800 times a year had
damaged the structural integrity of
their axon bundles the damage was
similar to how a rope will fail when the
individual fibers start to fray those
players also performed worse on
short-term memory tests so even though
no one suffered full-blown concussions
these sub-concussive hits added up to
measurable damage over time in fact
researchers know that an overload of
sub-concussive hits is linked to a
degenerative brain disease known as
chronic traumatic and
philosophy or CTE people with CTE suffer
from changes in their mood and behavior
that begin appearing in their 30s or 40s
followed by problems with thinking and
memory that can in some cases even
result in dementia the culprit is a
protein called tau usually tau proteins
support tiny tubes inside our axons
called microtubules it's thought that
repeated sub-concussive hits damaged the
microtubules causing the tau proteins to
dislodge and clump together the clumps
disrupt transport and communication
along the neuron and drive the breakdown
of connections within the brain
once the tau proteins start clumping
together they cause more clumps to form
and continue to spread throughout the
brain even after head impacts have
stopped the data show that at least
among football players between 50 and
80% of concussions go unreported and
untreated sometimes that's because it's
hard to tell the concussion has occurred
in the first place but it's also often
due to pressure or a desire to keep
going despite the fact that something's
wrong this doesn't just undermine
recovery it's also dangerous our brains
aren't invincible they still need us to
shield them from harm and help them undo
damage once it's been done
you
[Music]